[Musique]
pécresse valérie 54 ans candidate du
parti des républicains présidente de la
région ile de france c'est votre adn que
nous allons tenter de capter en
plongeant avec vous dans les archives de
l'ina bonjour et bienvenue valérie
pécresse bonjour et pour commencer je
vous propose de déterrer vos racines
la première fois vous apparaissez à la
télévision c'est pour protester avec
d'autres élèves de l'ena vous occuper
l'école pour refuser son transfert de
paris à strasbourg nous sommes en 91
vous avez 24 ans
ils s'y sentent tellement bien dans leur
école parisienne de la rue de
l'université qu'ils n'ont plus envie de
la quitter même la nuit son spot à jour
j'aurai l'honneur de me coucher sur la
moquette l'amphithéâtre jean moulin mais
ça démontre l impression que loin d'être
coupée la réalité sociale de ce pays
nous pouvions voir des prix que des
préoccupations terre à terre le grand
public ne connaît mal sinon il serait
qu'on n'est pas les polars en cravate et
weston mec
nous reconnaître en train de croiser
dans la rue nous sommes des hommes et
des femmes comme tout le monde disait ma
camarade des énarques ont un père une
mère j'espère qu'elle est actuellement
dans les consciences et tout ce que vous
direz sort oui oui je voudrais pas
revenir
combat perdu avec le recul vous diriez
mauvais combat
notre combat c'était pour dire que les
énarques et devaient être formés non pas
en province mais au plus près les
administrations centrales ce
déménagement à strasbourg il était très
symbolique c'était l'idée de
dalé m en province les les hauts
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui l'ena va être
une école de formation de toutes les
administrations
et aujourd'hui ce campus à strasbourg il
a trouvé son équilibre mais à l'époque
ça nous paraissait assez démagogique
comme proposition ça veut dire qu'il
faut pas toujours écouter les jeunes qui
n'ont pas toujours raison ça veut dire
que
en fait c'était vraiment surtout du
symbolique et que ça nous paraissait
effectivement
uniquement symbolique et pas très très
efficace sur le dans la pratique
d'ailleurs pendant des années les
énarques ont eu des problèmes à faire
venir leurs professeurs jusqu'à
strasbourg parce que les professeurs ne
voulait pas venir oui maintenant l'école
a trouvé son son équilibre et c'est tant
mieux pour elle vous préparez à une
carrière de haut fonctionnaire et
pourtant face à catherine ceylac dans
thé ou café vous lui confiez avoir rêvé
de tout autre chose
mais j'ai eu une enfance assez solitaire
parce que j'étais l'aînée de très loin
mes parents ou mon frère beaucoup plus
tard que moi et donc et donc j'étais
l'aînée j'étais donc assez solitaire et
alors tous mes petits cousins j'avais
l'habitude de leur faire jouer des
pièces de théâtre donc j'écrivais les
pièces de théâtre et je leur montrais
des pièces de théâtre et et voilà je
vous avais toujours et le spectacle oui
oui à l'époque je rêvais d'être actrice
et puis je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais pas le talent alors je me suis
orientée vers les besoins 19 janvier
si si si si j'ai essayé le théâtre
amateur mais j'étais pas assez jolie il
y avait beaucoup plu beaucoup plus jolie
pour jouer déjà deux premières à coup de
jeune première
non c'est vrai c'est vrai il ya aussi
les servantes
[Rires]
est ce qu'il reste un peu de comédienne
en vous dans ce théâtre politique
valérie pécresse je crois que la
politique c'est pas de la comédie et je
crois que c'est pas c'est pas être
acteur je crois que la politique c'est
celle des convictions je crois que la
politique c'est de l'action c'est très
différent de jouer un rôle du paraître
comme dans la politique il ya de la
séduction il a dû plaire mais à trop
plaire on oublie de faire et moi je suis
une femme qui fait un personnage qui a
beaucoup compté c'est votre grand père
maternel louis bertagna psychiatre grand
spécialiste de la dépression et les
troubles bipolaires
précurseur des traitements au lithium il
a soigné andré malraux romain gary jean
seberg ou encore la fille aînée de
jacques chirac laurence écouter le
parler de la dépression et de la grande
souffrance de la dépression en 83 dans
l'émission aujourd'hui la vie sur
antenne 2 est une des choses sur
lesquelles il faut insister
le mot de dépression est très souvent
très mal vécu voyez-vous tout à l'heure
madame deghilage nous disait que n'avait
pas vue de spécialistes et qu'elle avait
employé ce mot tout récemment seulement
dans les familles dire des quelqu'un de
la famille qu'il est déprimée c'est un
peu un déshonneur
en revanche quand on trouve des ascaris
quand on trouve des auc sûr quand on
trouve la photo ap des sites chronique
c'est l'honneur qui est restitué à la
famille et ce sont tous ces fameux bouc
émissaire salvateur parce que ils
viennent introduire l'élément somatiques
qui est lui parfaitement à voir or la
dépression non seulement est
parfaitement avoir et je dirais même que
pour moi dire de quelqu'un qu'il était
déprimé c'est presque lui rendent à nos
marques
non pas que je souhaite à quiconque
d'être déprimé car il n'y a pas
d'épreuve plus épouvantable que la
dépression mais la dépression existe je
la rencontre tous les jours et pour vous
donner une idée de son important je veux
donner quelques chiffres il y a en
permanence dans un pays comme le nôtre
3%
de personnes qui sont en dépression
grave 3% sas exception et million et
demi de personnes en permanence qui sont
en dépression g c'est-à-dire qu'ils
connaissent l'épreuve la plus
épouvantable qu'ils soient si on définit
la gravité d'une maladie par la douleur
la nuit au moral la dépression est pire
que toutes les douleurs physiques je
n'ai jamais vu un malade est primé qui
est éprouvée par ailleurs ce plan
physique ne pas dire mille fois ma
maladie physique plutôt que ma
dépression votre grand père louis
bertagna à vous en particulier valérie
pécresse que vous at il appris à ma mère
était son assistante donc j'ai grandi
effectivement après l'école chez mes
grands parents et j'ai vu les
souffrances
des malades parce que les patients
appelé au téléphone il appelé au
téléphone et il appelait il était
souvent en grande souffrance j'ai même
assisté à une scène assez dramatique
d'un patient qui était en train de
commettre une tentative de suicide qui
passait le dernier coup de fil à mon
grand-père donc tri par ma mère au
téléphone et donc céder c'est des
moments qui vous marque il m'a appris
que les âmes devait être réparé autant
que les corps lui c'était un médecin de
l'âme il était adoré par ses patients et
surtout il a fait reconnaître la
vulnérabilité de la dépression dans la
société française il a fait introduire
avec un certain nombre de deux collègues
médecins les médicaments pour soigner la
dépression les antidépresseurs il s'est
battu toute sa vie pour qu'on arrête de
dire que quelqu'un qui était déprimé
était juste mélancolique et devait juste
se prendre en main et c'était son combat
et réparer les âmes c'est aussi un petit
peu ça la politique est ce qu'il vous a
aidé parce qu'il a facilité votre
premier contact avec jacques chirac non
en réalité ce qui s'est passé c'est que
jacques chirac était à terre en 97 après
la dissolution ratée de l'assemblée
nationale et c'est le moment que j'ai
choisi pour lui envoyer une lettre de
candidature
donc je le revoyais lettre de
candidature en lui disant voilà vous
êtes abandonné par tout le monde moi je
souhaite vous rejoindre j'étais à
l'époque maître des requêtes au conseil
d'état j'ai été recommandé par denoix de
saint marc qui était le président le
vice-président du conseil d'état à
jacques chirac mais bien sûr jacques
chirac quand il m'a rencontrée la
première fois savais que j'étais à la
fois la petite fille de mon grand père
il savait aussi que j'étais mariée un
corrézien un corrézien dont
dont la cousine était était la femme de
son suppléant henri beyle court donc
effectivement la corrèze et mon
grand-père mais c'est pas là dessus qu
apporter notre notre premier entretien à
notre premier entretien à part a porté
sur deux éléments de mon cv qu'ils ont
intéressé l'internet parce que j'étais
spécialiste de l'internet et que l'ue
avait eu des problèmes avec le mulot et
le russe et japonais parce que j'avais
appris le russe et le japonais et que
lui aussi était fasciné par la russie et
le japon donc on a parlé de russes on a
parlé de russie on a parlé déjà pour on
a parlé de littérature est cet homme qui
était vraiment à terre politiquement à
terre je crois qu'il s'est pris
d'affection effectivement pour la jeune
femme qui venait essayer de le rejoindre
et que c'est comme ça que j'ai eus poste
le russe et la russie justement dans
votre
scolarité dans le privé à neuilly
fantaisie ou amour de tolstoï à
l'adolescence vous partez deux années de
suite en union soviétique dans un camp
de jeunesse du régime en guise de
vacances alors non nous n'avons pas des
images là nous séchons mais une archive
de cinq colonnes à la une en 67 ou le
journaliste marcel trillât part à la
rencontre de touristes français en urs
et dans un camp de pionnier que nous
avons rencontré la promotion sortante de
l'école centrale
une de ces remarquables colonie de
vacances où 80 % environ des enfants
soviétique instinct mois à chaque année
[Musique]
alors finalement peu de temps porter un
jugement sur l'urssaf et un voyage comme
celui ci pour ce même
trois semaines c'est vraiment d'être ici
nous avons visité un camp de jeunesse
communiste qui étaient des étudiants des
étudiants de l'université fief
finalement à vos propres nous n'avons
pratiquement pas rencontrer des
étudiants désirant parler aussi bien en
français qu'en anglais et puis ensuite
enfin je crois qu est ce qu une chose
qui existe en urss et qui est connue
plus ou moins on se fait aborder dans
les rues par des personnes qui cherchent
à vous achetez votre pantalon ou votre
chemise à condition qu'elle soit en 2011
et ces personnes là enfin nous n'avons
plus aucun contact
expliquez-nous valérie pécresse était le
le goût de l'aventuré la curiosité ou un
petit attrait pour le communisme ça ça
ressemblait pas du tout à ça moi c'était
dans la fin des années 80 donc ce
n'était pas du tout les années 60
c'était à l'époque une volonté de
l'union soviétique d'accueillir des
étudiants du monde entier
et ça ne ressemblait pas non plus à ça
du tout d'accueillir des étudiants du
monde entier dans des espèces de
colonies de vacances
assez assez assez
assez organisés et nous nous étions des
français mais nous n'étions pas du tout
des jeunes communistes donc nous étions
une bande de français qui venait à
prendre le russe et qui était invité à
venir séjourner dans ces camps alors
effectivement on a pu voir il y avait du
sport il y avait des activités mais il y
avait aussi des activités de
débats et l'idée c'était effectivement
de nous convaincre du bien fondé du
communisme mais mais là dessus on sait
on était très punchy et nous on était on
était vraiment les dissidents qui venait
porter une parole différente dans dans
le dans la dans la colonie de vacances
en disant que ben non le capitalisme
c'était parce qu on leur apprenait donc
on était assez on était assez mal vu de
de certains mais ça permettait du débat
est par ailleurs notre groupe visitait
l'union soviétique à partir de notre
base dans le camp voilà donc je n'ai pas
du tout fait ce genre de choses et comme
vous parlez encore le russe vladimir
poutine en vous entendant a vraiment cru
que vous étiez un agent des services
battante françois fillon me présente à
vladimir poutine il me dit il dit j'ai
un ministre qui a appris le russe est
alors la dîmière poutine se tourne vers
moi et me dit non pas pourquoi avez vous
appris le russe pas de chez vous mais il
me dit zatch m zem dans quel but avez
vous appris le russe est alors je lui
réponds que je l'avais pas de parents
communistes que je n'étais pas
communiste moi même mais que j'avais
appris le russe parce que j'aimais la
littérature russe tolstoï dostoïevski le
docteur jivago et là je vois dans son
regard qui ne me croit absolument pas et
qui se dit celle-là c'est c'est la
ministre qui représente les services
dans le gouvernement et et elle elle est
là pour pour nous espionner venant de sa
part je pense que c'était presqu'un un
compliment mais vous savez dans ces
camps ce qui est intéressant c'est que à
l'époque où j'y arrive avec mémé mes
camarades mes camarades français moi mon
livre préféré c'était le docteur jivago
et ja était tombée amoureuse d'omar
sharif qui jouait le docteur jivago à
l'écran et j'arrive et je rencontre ces
jeunes communistes ces jeunes soviétique
et je leur parle de boris pasternak de
docteur jivago qui était un prix nobel
de littérature russe soviétique et il
avait été censuré et là je mesure à quel
point le poids de la censure était
important à quel point le le communisme
était un lavage de cerveau et puis nous
visitions des usines nous visitions des
magasins et nous voyons
cette économie de la pénurie cette
économie qui était très en retard alors
quand je suis rentré en france de ses
voyages j'ai dit à mes professeurs
d'histoire géographie mais attendez vous
le dites que la russie c'est là l'union
soviétique c'est la deuxième puissance
mondiale mais est ce que vous savez que
dans les magasins il ya la queue qu'il
ya très peu de produits est ce que vous
savez que dans les usines tout est
rouillée tout est vieux est-ce que vous
avez vu que il roulait dans des toutes
petites voitures dépôt des pots de
yaourt et donc je suis rentré en en dix
ans en france dans dans ma classe la
réalité d'union soviétique que j'avais
perçu qu'il n'avait rien à voir avec ce
qu'on regardait dans les livres
d'histoire c'était pas le le paradis
annoncé non et surtout pas la grande
puisse enfin vous voyez la fragilité de
cette grande puissance bien avant la
chute du mur en tout cas quand on allait
en union soviétique à cette époque
apprendre le russe on s'apercevrait on
s'apercevait de toutes ses fragilités et
on s'apercevait aussi des ravages de
cette propagande absurde voyons
maintenant vous rendez totalement anti
communiste vos débuts en politique
rubrique big bang
est encore une surprise dans votre
parcours le 21 mai 81 vous n'avait que
13 ans mais vous prenez le métro avec
une amie pour assister à ceux ci
[Musique]
françois mitterrand se dégage de la
foule de rose à la main il pénètre seul
à l'intérieur du panthéon
[Musique]
orchestre de paris joue maintenant
l'hymne à la joie le président de la
république va se recueillir devant les
tombes au de jean jaurès et du résistant
jean nina
françois mitterrand au panthéon le jour
de sa prise de fonction vous étiez rue
soufflot là aussi curiosité oui
absolument absolument mais vous savez
moi j'étais d'une famille gaulliste
une famille gaulliste de toujours et
vous savez que les gaullistes se sont
beaucoup déchiré en 81 ils se sont
déchirés entre ceux qui sont restés
fidèles à la droite valéry giscard
d'estaing et ceux qui ont préféré voter
françois mitterrand et donc à table en
famille avec mes oncles mes tantes mes
cousins c'était des discussions
homérique sur giscard ou mitterrand et
donc moi je regardais ça je regardais ça
de l'extérieur je me suis dit qui sait
ce mitterrand et j'avais le sentiment
que cette élection présidentielle
c'était un moment un moment d'histoire
et donc avec une amie j'ai dit bah on va
aller voir le moment d'histoire et donc
on avait on avait 13 ans et on était on
est venu regarder ce spectacle au
panthéon et moi j'ai aimé le décorum
j'ai aimé le décorum de 2,7 de ce cette
marche vers le panthéon mais ensuite
j'ai regardé un peu plus tard les
actions de ce président mitterrand et là
j'ai pas du tout adhéré j'ai absolument
adhérer à rien j'ai adhéré nier aux
nationalisations nir à sa politique
économique ni à ce qu'il a fait de la
france donc je n'ai jamais voté pour
françois mitterrand à 25 ans vous entré
au conseil d'état où vous êtes
auditeurs ça s'est féminisé depuis je
crois qu'on dit maintenant auditrice
deux ans plus tard vous jouer les guides
pour l'émission de jean luc delarue ça
se discute
alors ici vous arrivez dans la salle
parodie c'est l'une des trois salles de
travail du conseil d'état c'est la salle
des jeunes rapporteur un rapporteur au
conseil d'état c'est la personne qui
examine en premier les affaires devant
nous la procédure est entièrement écrite
que nous rencontrons jamais ni les
requérants ni les défendeurs ni leurs
avocats on nous attribue un dossier et
dans ce dossier chaque partie a pu faire
valoir son point de vue donc mon rôle
c'est d'examiner ces différents mémoires
d'écrire une note de synthèse et de
proposer un premier projet du jour et
après le dossier quitte mon bureau et il
va être soumis à quatre filtres
successifs avant d'arriver au tribunal
la jeune femme souriante et volubile qui
fait des présentations ray vettel déjà
de deux politiques ou est ce qu'elle se
voyait passer toute sa vie au conseil
d'état moi je rêvais d'être juge je
rêvais d'être juges parce que malgré
effectivement l'arrêt dit et de cette
procédure du conseil d'état où on ne
rencontre pas les victimes il me
semblait que dire le droit c'était l'un
des plus beaux métiers du monde et
protéger les victimes aussi donc j'étais
spécialisée dans la responsabilité des
hôpitaux donc toutes les erreurs
médicales voyez vous rentrez à l'hôpital
et finalement eh bien il vous arrive un
accident
même parfois des malades trouvent la
mort donc c'était l'époque à l'époque
c'était l'époque du sang contaminé
c'était l'époque des années sida donc
c'était c'était des dossiers qui étaient
extrêmement douloureux et dans lesquels
on a complètement changé le regard sur
le pit à l'avant on ne jugeait que les
hôpitaux étaient une boîte noire et que
finalement circulé il y avait rien à
voir les médecins
devaient faire des fautes vraiment très
très graves pour pouvoir être condamné
et puis à cette période là on se rend
compte que c'est pas juste et que donc
il faut absolument changer les choses et
reconnaître la responsabilité y compris
100 kg et de fautes dès lors que
quelqu'un tombe malade à l'hôpital ou
que quelqu'un décède à l'hôpital donc
c'était un moment très fort pour le
droit pour la justice on a fait
progresser la justice et le droit et
et puis je jugeais aussi des choses plus
légères par exemple la question des
droits et des libertés fondamentales sur
internet qui démarrait qui débutait
c'était un petit peu plus tard donc vous
voyez c'était pour moi dire le droit
c'était quelque chose d'important rendre
la justice s'était c'était ma vocation
et à l'époque je n'imaginais pas faire
la politique du tout je pensais je
pensais peut-être faire plutôt une
carrière dans dans ces métiers du droit
dans ces métiers de la justice vous avez
raconté tout à l'heure votre entrée
votre arrivée à l'elysée en 97 c'est en
2002 que les portes de l'assemblée
nationale vont s'ouvrir pour vous après
la la réélection de jacques chirac vous
voici dans les yvelines et dans la joie
d'une campagne électorale
j'ai fait demi km en voiture j'ai fait
cinq réunions publiques déjà j'en ai
sept en préparation les gens me
demandent tous les jours de venir leur
parler dans leur petit village
c'est une impression extraordinaire dans
vie de politique et moi je m'amuse
vous amuser à découvrir la france les
gens c'est à dire le contraire un dieu
du conseil d'état ou l'elysée en fait au
fond de moi chez une femme d'action et
c'est vrai qu'au bout de huit ans au
conseil d'état a jugé je me suis dit
qu'il fallait que j'entre dans l'action
et jacques chirac venait de perdre les
élections et je me suis rendu compte que
si les lois étaient pas forcément
toujours bien fait celui qui avait le
pouvoir de les changer c'était le
politique et donc après avoir jugé en
appliquant des lois je me suis dit je
vais aller vers le politique je vais
aller faire celui qui fait la loi et
donc je suis je me suis mise au service
de jacques chirac aussi et d'abord par
conviction parce que la gauche venait de
l'emporter je voulais absolument l'aider
à a regagné je suis rentré chez jacques
chirac et jacques chirac ma vie la vraie
politique la vraie c'est se faire élire
c'est aller au contact du terrain c'est
conquérir la confiance des français et
donc en 2002 quand il a regagné les
élections présidentielles et bien au
lieu de continuer une carrière dans
l'administration
j'ai décidé d'aller me faire élire j'ai
décidé de me mettre mon destin dans les
mains des français déjà à l'époque et à
l'époque c'était une élection très
difficile parce que françois bayrou
m'avait envoyé le général morillon le
général morillon qui était un héros de
la guerre de bosnie qui venait
d'organiser les journées mondiales de la
jeunesse avec avec le pape qui était une
figure très connue et personne ne misait
un kopeck sur ma victoire dans dans les
yvelines terre de droite mais terre
extrêmement propice à l'arrivée du
général morillon et je me suis battu je
me suis battue comme une lionne vous
voyez j'étais jeune à l'époque j'étais
plein d' enthousiasme et j'ai surtout
été à la rencontre de chaque habitant de
la circonscription un parent en porte à
porte j'ai fait comme je le dis sur le
petit film des milliers de rencontres et
jungle et au général et j'ai gagné
signé par ce que parce que j'avais en
moi cette vraie envie de servir et je
pense que la politique c'est pas
seulement voilà le pouvoir pour le
pouvoir c'est d'abord se mettre au
service un quinquennat plus tard nicolas
sarkozy vous nomme au gouvernement à 39
ans plus jeune ministre du gouvernement
fillon avec pour mission de faire passer
la réforme sur l'autonomie des
universités et de tenir bon malgré
plusieurs mois de contestation
[Musique]
l'abrogation avant toute négociation
le seul mot d'ordre dans les rues de
paris et des grandes villes de france
ils sont plusieurs milliers d étudiants
et autant de lycéens rassemblés contre
la loi d'autonomie des universités
c'est mettre la pac au service de
brébeuf au service du patronat il n'y a
rien de bon a gagné leurs sept quarts
d'heure cette fois on ne peut pas
l'aménager et pourtant au ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur on discute cet
après midi valérie pécresse a reçu cinq
organisations étudiantes dont l'unef et
a fait des annonces et vous avez tenu
bon on réforme promulguée en août 2007
qu'avez vous appris de cette première
épreuve du feu valérie pécresse alors
effectivement c'était vraiment l'épreuve
du feu il ya eu neuf mois de grève
extrêmement violente
mais j'ai appris la concertation j'ai
appris la négociation j'ai appris la
décision et j'ai appris aussi le contact
avec l'ultra violence de l'extrême
gauche parce que on avait des présidents
d'université séquestré on avait des des
invasions ultra violente de l'université
l'objectif de l'extrême gauche était
d'avoir les images que vous montrez
c'est à dire des images de confrontation
extrêmement violente avec avec la police
donc déjà à l'époque une extrême gauche
qui voulait déstabiliser un gouvernement
besancenot à l'époque m'avait dit dans
une émission télé ce que nous n'avons
nous avons perdu dans les urnes mais
nous allons gagner dans la rue nous
allons gagner contre vous et son
objectif c'était vraiment de
déstabiliser le gouvernement
alors il fallait tenir il fallait tenir
et en même temps il fallait que
trouver des alliés trouver des alliés
c'étaient les grands chercheurs c'était
un certain nombre d'universitaires ça a
été les mouvements étudiants parce que
j'ai convaincu à l'époque nicolas
sarkozy françois fillon qu'il fallait
aussi négocier avec les étudiants
négocier sur le 10e mois de bourse
négocier sur la réussite en licence et
donc j'ai donné des contreparties pour
prouver que cette réforme de l'autonomie
des universités ne se faisait pas contre
les étudiants mais pour eux et alors ce
qui est intéressant quand on fait une ce
type de réforme c'est qu'on s'aperçoit
de quoi et bien avant la réforme tout le
monde hurle pendant la réforme c'est
très violent mais une fois que la
réforme est passée et bien tout va bien
tout le monde est content françois
hollande n'est pas revenu sur cette
réforme il n'a pas osé la détricoter
parce que finalement les universitaires
en était satisfait et aujourd'hui
malheureusement personne n'a eu le
courage d'aller à l'étape 2 de
l'autonomie mais l'étape de l'autonomie
elle est indispensable pour les
universités françaises pour qu'elles
soient à armes égales dans la
compétitive la compétition mondiale et
si vous regardez les classements des
universités dix ans après et bien vous
voyez quoi vous voyez des universités
françaises qui arrivent dans les dix
premières au classement de shanghai le
fameux classement des universités parce
qu'elles sont autonomes parce qu'elles
ont pu développer leur projet alors vous
voyez la politique c'est dur la
politique c'est un combat mais les
résultats c'est souvent 10 ans plus tard
et c'est des beaux résultats dont je
suis très fier et je suis très fier
parce que j'ai été dans ce combat aussi
soutenu par nicolas sarkozy et françois
fillon qui n'ont pas lâché leur ministre
parce que vous savez que dans ces genres
de réformes et bien les minis sont
souvent lâché oui c'est arrivé pour cet
adn nous avons aussi chercher vos
mentors
[Musique]
alors évidemment jacques chirac nicolas
sarkozy françois fillon alain juppé ont
accompagné votre parcours mais pour
l'inspiration politique vous avez cité
deux femmes en début de campagne deux
grandes dirigeantes angela merkel et
margaret thatcher
surnom en france comme ailleurs
c'est la dame de fer les matches est ce
que c'est une image qui vous glace
parfois ou bien est ce que c'est quelque
chose au fond qui
sollicite votre
tout président tout à premier ministre
doit être très ferme doit savoir ce
qu'il veut la façon dont je gère ma
politique m'amène à dire ce que je
pensais à lutter pour le secours ce que
je crois être juste je ne peux pas
changer ma façon d'être je ne souhaite
pas à changer du scar je crois que c'est
ainsi qu'un britannique et je pense que
cela va ajouter à la communauté chacun
d'entre nous en apportant notre style
nous ne voulons pas être des copies
conformes et un désordre nous voulons
être complémentaires je ne pense pas que
cela laisse mon image oui je suis très
ferme sur certains domaines pourquoi
parce que je crois en certaines choses
est ce que ce n'est pas normal de la
part d'un politicien bonsoir madame la
chancelière merci de nous recevoir une
question ou préliminaire un peu
personnel si vous le voulez bien à la
veille de ce g7 ça fait une décennie que
vous gouvernez l'allemagne est
régulièrement on vous désigne comme la
femme la plus puissante du monde est ce
que c'est une une satisfaction est ce
que c'est une fierté
et à la cause ma plus grande
satisfaction c'est que la politique que
je mène soit reconnu et bien sûr je me
réjouis un peu aussi pour moi cela
montre aussi qu'il y à montils partition
entre les femmes car nous sommes moins
nombreuses que les hommes qui dirigent
des états c'est pour ça qu'il faut
encore plus de femmes en politique
deux tiers merkel et un tir satcher av
vous dis mais on voit à quel point elles
sont différentes
que pensez vous avoir en commun avec
l'une et l'autre quand j'ai dit cela ce
que je voulais dire aux français c'est
que le pouvoir peut s'incarner au
féminin et je sais qu'il ya encore un
doute sur cette question est ce que une
femme peut tenir est ce qu'une femme
peut décider est ce qu'une femme peu
concerté montré qu'il y avait deux
femmes puissantes qui avait dirigé des
grands états voisins et qui était sans
doute des personnalités qui avaient
marqué leur époque pour moi c'était une
façon d'affirmer ma volonté d'incarner
un pouvoir féminin alors je les ai cité
toutes les deux parce que toutes les
deux elles ont un point commun elles ont
protégé et défendu leur peuple et moi si
je suis président de la république
président de tous les français je
protègerai les français je défendrai
leur intérêt et je me battrai comme une
lionne comme elle la rubrique suivante
est celle des changements ou des volte
face 180 degrés
[Musique]
contre le mariage homosexuel vous avez
manifesté valérie pécresse ici à
versailles à l'appel de la manif pour
tous en décembre 2013 six mois après le
vote de la loi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chez nous pour dire encore
on voit converser avec le maire de
versailles françois de mazières et aux
côtés de jean frédéric poisson qu'est ce
qui vous a fait évoluer sur ce sujet à
l'époque j'étais venu dialoguer avec la
manif pour tous après le vote de la loi
ils demandaient l'abrogation et moi je
leur ai dit que
humainement on ne pourrait pas revenir
sur cette loi pourquoi et bien parce que
une fois qu'elle est votée moi je suis
une républicaine et je considère que le
peuple s'est exprimé et sur ces sujets
de société c'est ce sera comme ça que je
présiderai la france ce que je souhaite
aujourd'hui c'est que les choix de
société qui sont des choix intime qui
relève de la conscience des personnes
restent des choix de conscience voilà et
moi j'ai mes opinions
j'étais à l'époque pour l'union civile
je défende l union civile est pas le
mariage parce que je pensais qu'il ne
fallait pas crispé la société parce que
je pensais qu'il fallait pas déchirer
les français mais aujourd'hui le mariage
est votée et en républicaine j'ai dit
dès 2013 que j'appliquerai la loi donc à
ce moment là vous allez à versailles
dans ce grand rassemblement en ne
reprenant pas le mot d'ordre de
l'abrogation de la loi quasi normalement
et d'ailleurs je me fais siffler parce
que je ne reprends pas ce mot d'ordre
d'abrogation vous prenez la parole lors
de ce rassemblement
rubriques suivantes
[Musique]
ce zéro pointé ne s'adresse pas vous
directement mais à votre famille
politique qui au fil du temps et de la
pression du front national notamment à
opérer quelques zigzags ou afficher
quelques désaccords sur les questions de
nationalité et d'immigration ce débat il
traverse la droite depuis plus de 20 ans
en 1991 dans une interview choc valéry
giscard d'estaing évoque ce site
l'immigration invasion
ce que les français souhaitent pour eux
pour eux c'est le droit du sang lorsque
un enfant né en france de parents
étrangers il devient il devient français
moi je dis je préfère qu'on devienne
français on dit en ayant demandé la
nationalité
je suis très attaché à la notion de
droit du sol pour une raison que je vous
expliquais c'est que je n'aime pas
l'idée du droit du sang qu'est ce que ça
veut dire le droit du sang vous savez
bien ce qu'ils en ont fait un certain
nombre c'est la pureté on ne devient
français par le sang ce que ça veut dire
la pureté du sang la france n'est pas un
pays d'immigration et nous devons nous
donner les moyens réglementaires et
administratifs de gérer un quota zéro
des migrants et les des quartiers
où je peux comprendre l'exaspération de
certains de nos compatriotes pères ou
mères de famille rentrant du travail le
soir
apprenant que leur fiche s'est fait
arracher son pain au chocolat à la
sortie du collège par des voyous il lui
explique qu on mange pas pendant le
ramadan
si vous ajoutez à cela
le bruit et l'odeur
est bien le travailleur français sur le
palier devient fou moi je suis pour une
vision de la société française qui
respecte d'abord notre diversité je suis
heureux d'ailleurs de voir que les
évêques de france vient d'écrire une
lettre qui dit exactement la même chose
nous sommes direct nous n'avons pas les
mêmes religions parlent même couleur de
peau par la même origine il faut
respecter cette diversité qui fait notre
richesse le racisme anti blanc seing
existe je le vis moi sur mon territoire
aux confins entre la haute loire et la
loire à proximité de saint-etienne ce
n'est pas en nous alignant si peu que ce
soit sur les positions et sur les tests
du front national ne nous dissuaderont
les électeurs de voter pour cette
formation politique
alors question pas facile pour qu'il
veut rassembler sa famille de quelles
paroles vous sentez vous la plus proche
ce que je crois c'est qu'une immigration
incontrôlée avec une intégration ratée
ça peut disloquer la nation est ce que
je crois aussi c'est que on est face à
ce défi aujourd'hui ce défi est réel ce
défi existe et ça va être le défi du
prochain quinquennat refaire nations
avec des français qui se regarde qui
vivent côte à côte et qui ne doivent pas
se retrouver face à face alors qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire reprendre
le contrôle des flux migratoires et des
entrées sur le territoire on a
aujourd'hui deux cent soixante douze
mille titres de séjour qui sont donnés
chaque année c'est évidemment trop c'est
ce que je pense nous avons des
détournements du droit d'asile colossaux
avec cent mille demandeurs d'asile dont
la majorité sera déboutée mais restera
en france et aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
possible ce n'est pas souhaitable c'est
pour ça que moi je souhaite une loi
constitutionnelle avec des quotas
migratoires et ses quotas selon un
principe très simple les pays d'origine
qu'ils ne reprennent pas leurs
clandestins n'auront plus droit aux
visas je vois d'ailleurs que le
président de la république emmanuel
macron qui avait été totalement
immobile et impuissant sur ce sujet a
commencé à bouger mais il agite un sabre
de bois puisque les visas qui l'a bloqué
sont des visas de court séjour et ses
visas de court séjour eh bien ils
peuvent être données dans n'importe quel
pays de l'union européenne donc
l'interdiction de visa des manuels
macron est aujourd'hui contourner voilà
donc je note que vous n'avez voulu citer
personne dans la galerie de portraits de
déclaration que quand vous a proposé et
parce que c'est moi la candidate c'est
ma ligne qui sera proposé aux français
celle que je porte et la phrase de
bernard stasi prononcé ya trente ans
n'est pas en s'alignant sur les thèses
de l'extrême droite que nous
dissuaderont ses électeurs et ce qu'elle
vous parle aujourd'hui d'abord on n'est
pas du tout sûr les mêmes thèses nous on
est pour des solutions qui vont
fonctionner l'immigration zéro ça
n'existe pas ça ne marchera pas et il
faut une immigration de travail il faut
aussi une immigration étudiante il faut
limiter l'immigration familiale dans la
mesure où nous voulons des personnes qui
parlent le français qui passent un
examen de français qui est des
ressources suffisantes pour s'intégrer
et qui respecte les valeurs de la
république
mais aujourd'hui nous avons des
solutions pour reprendre le contrôle de
l'immigration et c'est pas en niant le
problème c'est pas en faisant comme s'il
n'existait pas que nous reconquerrons la
confiance des français vous savez
aujourd'hui il y à 30% des français qui
veulent voter au premier tour pour des
extrêmes et bien ça c'est le bilan des
manuels macron c'est le bilan d'un
président qui n'a pas voulu voir les
problèmes et surtout qui n'a pas su les
régler alors je vais quand même vous
entraîner à nouveau dans le passé et
c'est un peu la philosophie de
l'émission comme son ombre et son
héritage plane sur cette campagne nous
invitons chaque candidat à se placer
face à de gaulle
et nous avons choisi pour vous une
archive peu connue du général est très
peu citer cet extrait d'un entretien
télévisé avec michel droit juste après
mai 68 de gaulle y vante la
participation troisième voie selon lui
entre le communisme et le capitalisme
qu'il rejette presque dose ado écoutez
le capitalisme dit
grh au profit qui suscite l'initiative
fabriquons
de plus en plus une richesse qui en se
répartissant par le libre marché élève
en somme le niveau du corps social tout
entier
seulement voilà la propriété la
direction le bénéfice des enfants
le système capitaliste n'appartient
qu'au capital est alors ceux qui le
possèdent pas se trouve dans une sorte
d'état d'aliénation à l'intérieur même
de l'activité à laquelle y contribuer
non
le capitalisme du point de vue de
l'homme
n'offrent pas de solution satisfaisant
le
capital qui aliène ceux qui ne possèdent
pas réaction de la gaulliste que vous
êtes je suis totalement dans sa qui je
veux réconcilier le capital et le
travail et je pense que c'est possible
je pense que c'est souhaitable et c'est
pour cela que dans la politique
économique que je prône il y à la
revalorisation des salaires et du
travail par la baisse des cotisations
sociales pour permettre à tous les
salariés de se voir mieux reconnus dans
leur travail que le travail paye plus
que l'assistance et puis il ya la
possibilité pour les entreprises de
mieux associer leurs salariés aux
bénéfices c'est la participation chère
au général de gaulle c'est
l'intéressement je vais supprimer le
forfait social qui pèse sur les
entreprises lorsqu'elle donne de
l'intéressement et de la participation
je vais permettre aux pme de verser sans
impôts des primes à la fin de l'année à
leurs salariés une prime annuelle comme
ça a pu être fait pendant la crise qu
vide il faut que ça puisse à nouveau se
faire mon objectif c'est aussi d'avoir
de l'actionnariat salarié est d'inciter
les entreprises qui le peuvent et qui le
souhaitent à donner des actions
gratuites à leurs salariés à les
associer au capital et je mettrai des
incitations fiscales là encore pour ce
faire je crois effectivement pour moi
que il n'y a rien de plus terrible que
d'opposer le capital et le travail qu'
au contraire il faut les réconcilier je
crois un état stratège et je ne crois
pas je crois que aujourd'hui c'est
l'ensemble de nos travailleurs des
français qui travaillent qui font
l'économie aux côtés des chefs
d'entreprise qui entreprennent et chefs
d'entreprise prennent beaucoup de
risques leurs salariés doivent aussi
être valorisé c'est ma vision du
capitalisme récompensés et aider ceux
qui créent les entrepreneurs récompensé
aider les salariés allez on va laisser
un peu la politique nous avons trouvé
aussi une madeleine
une madeleine ou une pavlova peut-être
puisque nous avions envie de chatouiller
votre amour de la culture russe et de
ses auteurs avec une grande question
posée dans une émission littéraire de
l'eau et rtf en 63
tolstoï ou dostoïevski un essai de
george steiner vous écrivez demandé un
homme s'il préfère tolstoï dostoïevski
vous connaîtrez le secret de son coeur
au quoi faire de tolstoï et dostoïevski
ces cas limites en quelque sorte c'est
qu'un test il est des oeuvres d'art qui
nous force en quelque sorte à choisir
parce qu elle vous prennent à la gorge
pour ainsi dire et elles disent voilà
une vision du monde de dieu de votre
rôle dans le monde
choisissez entre nous on les visions
opposées antagonistes et pour moi ce
sont là les deux géants du roman qui est
après tout la forme contemporaine par
excellence la forme qui a succédé au
poème épique au drame tragique nous
sommes dans le siècle si vous voulez ou
dans le second siècle du roman et ce
sont les deux grands maîtres de cette
forme et quoi que nous puissions les
apprécier tous deux je crois que chaque
homme en soit choisi l'un plutôt que
l'autre
c'est à dire disons 'peut-être que
simplifier les choses le rationalisme
et puis d'autre part l'irrationnel
dostoïevski en sommet pour simplifier
dit au monde entier si vous voulez le
royaume de la justice sur terre au rayon
de la raison vous aboutissez par la
ruine par l'inhumain par le monde
concentrationnaire qu'il a prévus dans
les possédés et rae karamazov et tolstoï
dit non c'est ici qu'il faut bâtir le
royaume de l'homme et de dieu et si vous
et vous esquivez en pensant au ciel au
transcendant alors vous aboutirez par
l'injustice et les deux solutions sont
antagonistes et très ennemis elles ne
savent même pas égales en tout 2 et je
crois d'instinct de raison de
sensibilité le choisissant alors valérie
pécresse dans secret de votre coeur
tolstoï ou dostoïevski
[ __ ] de stay skis et le de ses skis de
crime et châtiment
très bien
une archive à présent que nous
soumettons à tous les candidats
l' alerte verte c'est celle que rené
dumont le premier candidat présidentiel
écologistes agité dès 1974 vous savez ce
qui va se passer eh bien nous allons
bientôt manquer de l'eau et c'est
pourquoi je bois devant vous un verre
d'eau précieuse puisque avant la fin du
siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle manquera à lundi je
vous dis au revoir et j'espère vous
revoir pour vous expliquer notre projet
global d'avenir merci mes amis de
alerte qui a mis du temps beaucoup de
temps à être prise au sérieux valérie
pécresse oui alors j'appartiens comme
vous le savez à une filiation où on
s'est beaucoup préoccuper d'écologie que
ce soit jacques chirac avec le discours
de johannesburg que ce soit nicolas
sarkozy avec le grenelle de
l'environnement moi cette préoccupation
écologique
elle est très forte en moi comme
ministre de la recherche j'ai fait
tranché l'académie des sciences sur
l'existence dû réchauffement climatique
et sur la responsabilité de l'homme dans
ce réchauffement à l'époque vous savez
claude allègre aller sur les plateaux et
désespéré les climatologues en disant
que le réchauffement climatique
n'existait pas et le fonctionnement
médiatique étant ce qu'il est sur les
plateaux il y avait 1 pour 1 contre et
un journaliste au milieu qui ne
prenaient en général pas partie donc les
climatologues m'avait saisi en disant
fait rétabli c'est la vérité et donc
j'ai fait tranché l'académie des
sciences c'était une des dernières
académie qui s'était pas prononcée
encore sur le sujet alors cette urgence
climatique elle nous oblige est l'un des
grands enjeux du prochain mandat
c'est celui que qui est décrit dans
votre dans votre dans votre petit
extrait c'est celui de la gestion de
l'eau qui va devenir une question très
dramatique avec le réchauffement nous
avons besoin de respecter les
engagements de la conférence de paris
aujourd'hui la france ne respecte aucun
donc nous devons nous mettre dans une
trajectoire qui nous amènera au zéro
carbone 2050 nous devons nous mettre
dans une trajectoire qui préservera les
ressources de la planète mais ma
conviction c'est que l'écologie c'est
pas une idéologie
l'écologie c'est des résultats concrets
c'est des résultats en termes de baisse
de pollution c'est des résultats en
termes d'énergies propres et des
résultats en termes de sobriété de
consommation s'est inventé une nouvelle
croissance qui sera sobre parce que moi
je ne crois pas à la décroissance pas
dans un pays avec des difficultés
sociales aussi forte que la france nous
avons besoin de ne pas opposer
l'écologie à l'économie mais c'est toute
l'économie qu'il faut redéfinir
construire réinventer une rencontre
enfin à vous proposer
[Musique]
rencontre avec une grande voix dénicher
parmi les trésors de l'ina il s'agit
d'albert jacquard célèbre biologiste et
généticien français disparus en 2013 à
propos de compétition il faut être
violent contre la compétition il faut
être violent contre la violence de même
que la seule guerre bonne nous dit là
des pierres c'est la guerre contre la
misère est bien la seule violence est la
violence contre la violence car vous
faut être compétitif ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire vouloir passer devant un
autre et on apprend que ça à l'école
dans aviator non c'est pas ça on
apprenait autrefois et qu'il soul et les
grands personnages qui ont fait avancer
la science comme faire avancer la pensée
humaine il n'était pas compétitif et
sketches teigne était compétitif
absolument pas il se battait contre
personne il n'avait pas envie d'arriver
le premier il avait envie de comprendre
des choses qu'ils n'arrivaient pas à
comprendre est que les autres croyaient
avoir compris mais devrait bientôt via
lui se battait contre lui-même la
compétition mais faut y réfléchir un peu
chaque fois que l'on accepte la
compétition on accepte mes petits c'est
quelqu'un de le détruire et on est en
train de se détruire soi même puisque un
beau jour on perdra c'est pas sérieux ni
pour un état ni pour une collectivité
quelconque ni pour un individu être
compétitif ça ne peut pas être le bon
moteur il ya d'autres moteurs dans la
vie et malheureusement on nous raconte
aussi que la sélection naturelle veut
que les meilleurs gagnent c'est faux
s'est jamais le meilleur qui gagne on
gagne pas simplement il faut survivre il
faut avancer il faut être meilleur que
soi même c'est complètement différent
mais quand est-ce qu'on l'aura compris
je crois que actuellement le drame de
notre de la terre entière sait que la
société qui domine la nôtre a pris comme
moteur la compétition mais il faut y
réfléchir c'est forcément un poison la
compétition ainsi dénoncé par albert
jacquard at-elle été le le moteur de
votre vie et vos ambitions
non le moteur de ma vie de mes ambitions
c'est changer la vie changer la france
la rendre encore plus forte plus belle
c'est vraiment l'amour de mon pays et
puis aussi l'amour des français
depuis que je fais de la politique j'ai
rencontré énormément de français j'ai
rencontré énormément de souffrance de
problème j'ai rencontré aussi
énormément de questionnements moi j'ai
appris vous montrez vous montrer les
écoles qui m'ont formé les maîtres qui
m'ont formé j'ai appris que dans la vie
quand on avait beaucoup reçu quand on
avait eu beaucoup de chance et c'est mon
cas j'ai une famille heureuse j'ai
grandi dans un milieu protégé quand on a
beaucoup reçu on doit beaucoup donné et
vous savez la devise de deux de mes
écoles ça a été servir c'était servir
servir
la devise de mon lycée servir sens à
servir la devise de l'ena et donc je
crois à cette notion de service alors en
même temps la compétition fait partie de
la vie la compétition elle existe une
campagne électorale c'est une
compétition donc pour pouvoir avoir les
moyens de faire il faut gagner des
batailles donc je me bats je gagne des
batailles mais l'objectif pour moi c'est
pas la bataille s'est pas de gagner la
bataille l'objectif pour moi c'est de
servir au terme de cet adn et de ce
voyage dans les archives de l'ina y at
il un morceau essentiel de votre adn
valérie pécresse que nous avons manqué
un morceau essentiel de mon adn que vous
avez manqué
sans doute peut-être mon amour de la
corrèze de ce terroir de cette terre de
france dans laquelle je me suis ancré il
ya 27 ans et qui est devenu un refuge
qui est devenu un lieu dans lequel
au contact de la nature au contact de
cette france des villages et bien
j'équilibre ma connaissance de la france
des villes
merci valérie pécresse
[Musique]